أعتقد أن أوليفر
ويندل هولمز قال إن إف دي آر كان يتمتع
بذكاء من الدرجة الثانية ولكن
مزاجه من الدرجة الأولى أفكر في
ميركل يمكننا القول إنها تتمتع
بذكاء من
الدرجة الأولى وأن ألمانيا من الدرجة الأولى
قد
خدمها جيدًا.  سنواتها التي بلغت 16
عامًا تحولت
لأنها لم تستقبل مليون لاجئ فحسب
، بل قامت أيضًا بتحويل البلد إلى
بلد كان أكثر ودية تجاه
الأقليات من النساء ، مما
جعل
المساواة في الزواج هو حكم الأرض ،
هذه كلها أشياء يمكن أن
تنسب لها الفضل.
فيما
يتعلق بمستقبلها ومستقبل أوروبا ،
أعتقد أنها ستفعل ذلك لأنها عالمة مدربة
أعتقد أنها
ستلاحظ رد فعلها
على ما يعنيه أن تكون
حراً لأول مرة في حياتها ،
أعني 35 عامًا في دولة بوليسية  16 عاما
كمستشار
16 عاما كانت حقا
أزمة متدحرجة أه من الانهيار المالي أه 2008
إلى أه
إخفاق الطاقة النووية
أه إلى أم إلى عصر ترامب
أم الذي كان هو  التحدي الأكبر في
تلك السنوات الأربع ، لذا لم
تتح لها أبدًا فرصة للتنفس أو التركيز
على ما أتوقع
أنها ستركز عليه بعد ذلك بمجرد أن
تتوقف قليلاً عن
جدارة وتستمتع بحريتها وهذا هو
تغير المناخ لأنها  هي
عالمة ، وكانت قد بدأت لتوها
في موضوع تغير المناخ عندما ضرب فيروس
كوفيد ، وتحت ذلك ، أظهرت
مدى أهمية أن يكون لديك رئيس
دولة
يشعر بالراحة مع
الحقائق والأرقام التي يمكن أن
توضح مسار المرض
الذي وصلت إليه ألمانيا  أفضل
من معظم البلدان نتيجة
لقيادتها لذلك أعتقد أنها ستعود
بعد فترة
إلى المسرح العالمي لعدم تولي
أي وظائف
لأن الوظيفة الموجودة هناك بعد 16 عامًا
كمستشارة للقوة الاقتصادية الأوروبية
لكن أه ولكن
كلاعب في المناخ
في تغير المناخ الذي تأسف
لأنها لم تفعل ذلك ، أود أن أقول
لك الإجابة الكاملة على سؤالك حول
إرثها.
د أقول إن أه من بين كل هذه
الأشياء
أنا على
رأس القائمة أود
أن أضعها بأنها حولت الرايخ الثالث السابق
منذ جيلين
كانت ألمانيا النازية
إلى المركز
الأخلاقي ليس فقط لأوروبا بل للعالم
لا أرى أي شخص آخر يتنافس على هذا
المنصب
، إنه سجل رائع
وليس مفيدًا للنساء فقط لأنها
وضعت راحة دائمة في القدرة
أه أي أسئلة باقية
حول قدرة المرأة على القيادة
ولكن أه
إذاً عظيم عظيم نعمة عظيمة
للنساء لكن أه لكن نعمة عظيمة لأه
لمن ييأس من أه
تلك الديمقراطية
والإنسانية وكل ما
بعد الحرب العالمية الثانية
أه القيم التي اعتقدنا
أنها
ثابتة و  موضوع دائم الآن لقد
أوضحت طريقة أه
يمكننا الحفاظ عليها ، لذا
فهي هي التي حصلت عليها من الراحة.